my guess this week is a comedian an
author an actor and a Twitter Nazi
hunter Michael Ian Black welcome to the
show thank you
which one of those would you say you
mostly are is it Twitter Nazi hunter or
comedian probably Twitter Nazi honor
yeah yeah because I'm not particularly
funny these days on Twitter
I'm just annoying you are fighting the
Nazis constantly on Twitter uh-huh and
my policy with the Nazis is
congratulations you guys came up with a
meme and you're alone in your basement
yeah but you like engaging these people
mm why don't you like it I don't want to
put words in it but you do engage these
people I think it's I think it's
valuable and important to engage these
people yeah because I think it's worth
the the larger public knowing that
they're out there yeah knowing that
there is this sub subculture I don't
even know how large it is I'm assuming
it's very small yeah if I sub sub yeah
but they are very vocal and my sense is
there are more sympathizers than actual
participants and so it's I feel sort of
duty-bound to hold to hold them up as
idiots so that those who may be inclined
to sympathize though oh wait they're
idiots yeah they're always anonymous -
right are you ever fighting a Nazi
that's like hi I'm a Nazi you know this
is my real picture nuke
it's always it's always either some
prepubescent Japanese anime yeah they
avatar yeah yeah or some repurposed like
Hitler Youth avatar right what are you
making the Japanese anime thing with
related to that cuz I don't think
there's any connections between Japanese
and no not between Japanese anime and
Hitler but there's absolutely some kind
of connection between those who would
move towards that ideology and
fetishizing prepubescent Japanese girls
there's absolutely a connection there
I'll leave it to brighter Minds than
mine to try to
tie those two things together but that
absolutely exists right you're just
exposing them and now it's for the
social scientists that's right to figure
out that do you are you ever afraid that
sometimes that by fighting with them
that it's almost like elevating their
relevance they're not not fighting with
him but by exposing them and are you
there's absolutely a case to be made for
that yeah and but I think it's I think
it's more important from my point of
view to show that they're there and just
say look this is this is who we're
living among and in the context of the
current political climate I think it's
important to let people know that these
people exist and that given the right
circumstances more of them could pop up
yeah now I take it you're not against
you wouldn't be for banning them right
like you're just you're exposing them
but you would let them do their to what
you do that's that's why we have a first
amendment yeah all right so no and I
don't report them you know I don't do
any of that [ __ ] yeah I just I I just
show them yeah
okay so let's back up to the first thing
you said which is I used to be funny is
that we said I used to be funnier I am
not I'm not I'm not
yeah I'm just annoying yeah so I feel
that since I've been doing this I mean I
did stand-up in twelve twelve years in
New York and a couple of years out here
I used to be funny uh-huh I was I mean I
can get you some letters to show you
later I was funny at one time but now
I'm talking about all the serious stuff
all the time but I like to try to pepper
some comedy in there when I can but
there's the world just feels
particularly crazy right now doesn't it
which should be ideal for comedy right
but I'm not I'm not good at making light
of things that I find deadly serious I'm
just not good at it I mean there's
there's great political comedians out
there and I'm not one of them yeah I can
talk about my own life I think in a
funny way but I can't I mean there's
there's there's people better able to
talk about Trump and be hilarious they
mean yeah so we'll get to Trump in a
second so you I always think of you more
so as or until the last year or so I
always thought of you more as like
social commentary oh I love the eighties
stuff all that's
a lot of the movies you've been it
soared more like personal social
commentary did you ever think you were
gonna be more in the political sphere
cuz that's sorta where I put you now
well I mean I don't not gonna serve
myself in the political sphere now I
mean the last thing the world needs is
another jerk-off community X pouting off
about politics I don't I don't aspire to
be that person yeah but if I can set
aside being a comedian and just be a
citizen who's interested in this stuff
that's sort of how I view myself yeah I
mean I definitely am NOT I'm not an
activist I'm not marching I take no
action
I do nothing other than I have this
Twitter platform and that's that's how I
express myself politically yeah you do
tweet while flying first class yeah
because that's the first time we had any
face-to-face interaction I was going to
you know Rick going way in the back and
you sort of dismissively waved it was
already it was embarrassing for both of
you as a first class I've only flown
first class at once and it was on a
little plane from Detroit to New York so
it was like I mean people and I was
first class it was just that I was in
the first seat right wasn't anything
special but as a first class fire you do
you feel it we shouldn't be allowed to
look at you I always feel like when I'm
walking through I shouldn't be allowed
to your misunderstanding part and maybe
the main joy your first class which is
we're seated first yeah so that so you
can people walking back are forced to
look at us already ensconced in our
blanket already ordering our beverage of
choice maybe you're already asleep maybe
getting massaged from the chair like
there's all kinds of things that it's
important for the business run all of
the airlines and for my own self-esteem
walking back to steerage that I have
that you do not right that's interesting
because I always thought there should be
one-way glass so that you could gawk at
us but that we would no desire to see
you yeah you don't exist for me
completely very much exist for you yeah
Wow you're thinking about those [ __ ]
in first class while you're crammed
sardine little C stewing for the
duration of your flight on that JetBlue
flight though JetBlue lets you get your
own soda you know you can go to like a
thing and I was almost gonna peek around
the curtain and just like oh they would
have a corded you out and I know you
would have called people and it would it
would they would have landed us in Salt
Lake City here's I think it would have
been it's a it
in a disaster I'm glad you didn't do
that I'm glad you had the foresight to
know better than to do that yeah you
would've been escorted out immediately
yeah well speaking of social faux pas
let's move over to trump because you
have written a children's book about
Trump yes so you must love Trump I
assume if you wrote a children's
everyone loves children's books and
here's my problem
despise Trump wrote a book about Trump
sort of a kind of a children's book a
parody of a children's book but it's a
children's book at the same time so I am
exploiting the Trump brand as much as an
actual Trump and making money off the
Trump brand so I don't know so you're
using heels right you're using a
trumpian tactic that's on Trump that's
right yeah
where did the idea to make it a
children's book come from I was at a
bookstore and I saw a book about Hillary
Clinton I sort of you know children's
book a rags to riches story about
Hillary Clinton in an inspirational tale
directed I think at young girls and it
made me chuckle a bit to think about
what that would be like if you were to
write about Trump because he's not an
inspirational figure in any way shape or
form he's just a toad and so I I just
thought love will let me try to do that
yeah so if he's a toad is that why
they're used you know that toad yang
yeah yeah is that where did that come
from absolutely yeah I don't know it
he's a toad with Trump hair but there's
a lot of toads yeah
on that part of the internet hey what's
with the toad I don't know we don't know
we have no idea I don't know it took me
long enough to figure out what the 3
parentheses meant
yeah wait this wait so the to know it's
3 to be Jewish or the 3 yeah
that's it's yeah I see oh because they
came but there was some list or
something that was exposed where they
tried to expose people that worked or
something that came later the the three
parentheses is meant to indicate an echo
right and it's like the Jewish echo I'm
not sure quite what that means but
that's what the three parentheses are
meant to indicate it's not just that
like a nagging mother I don't
think so I think it's in something worse
I think it's far worse man
and then there was an app that just
identified Jews for you right I don't
know it's insane yeah so what do you
make of just the general climate right
now cuz to me I've been off until this
show and we did one more we launched
relaunch last week and for the three
weeks that I took off so to speak it
seems like the world no the world I
wasn't paying attention I just didn't
have a show to talk about it and it
seems like the world went even more
crazy but don't you think the last month
seems like particularly nuts you know
sort of starting probably we're not
appalled shooting and then I mean I got
to I'm I'm I'm past the point of being
surprised that anything is happening
yeah it all feels of a piece to me and I
feel like I can kind of grasp the
outlines of what that piece is which is
that they didn't to me the larger story
is sort of what what is what is fueling
all of this and I think there's and I
look I'm I'm not particularly savvy
about this I'm just probably
regurgitating what I've read but it
really does feel like we're at a moment
where the foundations of capitalism are
are crumbling yeah and nobody knows what
to do so is that the scary part that
nobody knows what to you because I I
agree it feels like something that
there's like a real shift happening
right now and it's almost like we have
no leaders well even if you love Trump
and if you have loved Clinton and
Obama's on the way out but even if you
love him that we don't have leaders who
talk to us in an honest way and that
that's part of the problem like we're
all walking around like could somebody
like I feel like everyone's looking
around could somebody help here is there
anyone we could look to for a little
honest well I don't first final think
Trump understands the problem better
than the a let's say the average citizen
he knows how to exploit it but I don't
think he understands it but I agree with
you that there is not no sort of global
leader has stepped forward in a
articulate non condescending way to say
this is what we're going through yeah
and here's where I think we need to move
it would be great if somebody would do
that I'd love for Hillary Clinton to
spend an hour just talking into the
camera and saying this is where I think
we are this is why I think we're here
this is where I think we need to go yeah
in a very mature non alarmist way yeah
are you a Hillary supporter I mean I
think I have the enthusiasm for Hillary
that a lot of people have which is yeah
I could just picture the gift right
there I said are you Hillary's quitter
the other way you got it because that's
what everyone does no one's like there's
very very I know there's a couple but
everyone's supporting Hillary my friends
that have been Democrats their whole
life and family members are you
supporting Hillary well but there's good
reason for that it was easy to gin up
that enthusiasm for Obama mm-hmm because
as he himself said he was a blank slate
Hillary has a 2530 year record and it's
very easy to cherry pick what you like
and cherry pick what you don't like them
and say she's a villain say she's a hero
she's a flawed human being as we all are
and we know what her flaws are so it's
like you know it's it's like getting
back together with an old girlfriend or
something you're like it you know right
I still love her
right you know gonna be a pain in the
ass damn it I still love her yeah that's
kind of what it's like so is that a
little that's kind of dangerous thought
though because Obama came in with the
blank slate and whether you like him or
not the idea that we'd only be okay with
blank slate well that's what's the
appeal of Trump right now yeah even
though his slate actually is full of
stuff again whether you like it or not
well it's full of karnataka literary
stuff yeah so he you know one hand races
with the other hand wrote he can be
whatever you want him to be as long as
he's a racist because that's ultimately
what people want from him so what do you
make of the people and I get this part
here's my part of Trump that I do
actually get forget all the policies for
a second but I do get the part about you
forget the policies cuz there's they're
all over the place right and I've even
had his I've had Arden Trump supporters
sit here like my low you know
sit here and basically tell me it's not
about the policies it's about this one
thing that I'm gonna tell you and I said
I at least get this part which is that
this is a cultural election this time it
has almost nothing to do with policy but
the one thing that he's getting with
people and I've seen this when I've been
to colleges when liberals are coming up
to me and saying this that he's cracking
this political correctness thing now the
irony of that is I don't think he's
going to be some major free speech
beacon because he talks about suing
reporters all the time but at that but I
do get the level of people are feeling
very repressed right now like they can't
say anything and they're always screamed
at and called racist and all that stuff
but I don't think you're with me on that
not at all
yeah I think when Milo talks about
political correctness that term
political correctness has come to mean I
think in those circles
nativism racism xenophobia and
what-have-you
when you say he's cracked political
correctness what he's what he's cracked
is the the agreement that we had been
coming to as a society and that
agreement was diversity is a benefit to
the nation and tolerance is a benefit to
the nation and having different points
of view is a benefit to the nation that
has all gotten lumped into that
agreement has gotten lumped under
political correctness and when he says
he's cracked political correctness what
he's what I think he means is he has
he's attempting to unravel that
agreement and what's left is white
nationalism and nothing else
yeah because Trump's appeal he's not
policy based he has none it's not
judgment based he seems to have no
better judgment than anybody else and
possibly worse it's not principled base
he has none it's not character based
he has very little to none all he has is
on day one
starting with Mexicans are rapists and
whatever else he said that's what he has
and he's built on that from that's been
his entire campaign has been
divisiveness and hatred geared towards
angry white males yeah well I love I
love hearing your answer on that because
obviously I've I like Milo and I've
given him a platform and you know we
work together and stuff but the whole
point of my show is that I want to hear
that and I want to hear what you're
saying
well and when I've watched you shards
I've watched him on it and you know I
think he's a disgrace I think he's an
utter disgrace I have a feeling you're
gonna hear from him on Twitter I very
well might but he's not verified so at
least it starts from there and it feels
very calculated and it feels very
Machiavellian to me and it feels very
put on and it in it and he is allowing
himself to be used I think as a tool by
the intolerant right and the fact that
he's gay for example is is is makes it
all the more appalling to me because
he's giving them more a license to say
well we like this guy mm-hmm you know we
like this crazy Brit this crazy flaming
bread or whatever and that is I think an
unconscionable use of moral licensing
and then he's allowing himself to be
used in that way yeah and in promoting
himself in that way more a licensing I
like that just come up with that right
there know that that's something
somebody said that before I learned it
from Malcolm Gladwell okay they so
moralizing so I guess part of this is
that our system is just so broke that
anyone that had a moral license or a
moral compass would you ever want to run
for president I mean could you imagine
as as a smart person ever wanting to put
yourself into politics at all no no yeah
is that the bigger problem here that
we're we're just getting what we're just
getting what we've created right yeah I
mean if you if you have any if you've if
you've lived any kind of life Hemingway
for example Kerouac whoever those guys
could not run for office or anybody
who's lived a life that has any human
experience right so meaning you might
have cheated on your wife you might it
if you might get some coke sure yeah you
might have done any number of things
that make us human
make us flawed human beings mm-hmm you
know that stuff's gonna come up you know
you're gonna be vilified you know so if
you're thinking about running for office
somebody like Ted Cruz for example who's
been thinking about being president his
entire [ __ ] life yeah he's lived his
life in such a way to make his resume
the resume of a future president or very
least a senator you're not exaggerating
by the way there's no deal of him at
like 16 veteran said I'm gonna I'm gonna
be President yeah and so you live your
life in a way that is calculatedly
unrelatable to the rest of the nation
you know someone like Bill Clinton who I
think probably was running for president
his whole life too at least he he wears
his humanity on his sleeve he's like I'm
you know I'm just a big goober yeah and
that's part of his appeal but I can't
imagine subjecting myself to the kind of
public scrutiny that is required knowing
that there's people whose job is to dig
up [ __ ] on you just about your personal
life yeah there's nothing to do with
your ability to make good policy
decisions yeah what does it tell you
that when a show what's the show with
Kevin Spacey it's been plenty concerns a
car and a house of cards i watch house
of cards and i think wow there's a lot
more reality in that than anything that
i'm watching on CNN meanwhile all the
CNN people are pretending to be
themselves I hate that by the way deep
wait do you like rhymes me [ __ ] crazy
I read uh what movie was I watching just
this past couple days ago I was watching
one of the unjust some act you know
superhero movie right and it's like Jake
Tapper shows everybody it was Jake who I
liked I think it was Jake like what what
movie was it superhero movies Oh Batman
Batman Superman I don't know if it was
Jake actually no it was Anderson Cooper
huh in that when I was like you guys are
all pretending to be yourselves why
can't we have alternate universes where
there are also we could have kryptonite
while also we can have alternate
newscasters I'd be a journalist be a
journalist yeah don't show up in Batman
Yeah right but doesn't that show it it's
like they all want to be stars yeah and
I and I say this it's probably with some
do irony to people that are public
people and share our opinions but it's
like they all want to be in right they
go to the White House Correspondents
Dinner yeah they all want to have dinner
with these people and go to the parties
and all that backs to me one of the
biggest problems we have in the whole
country
well this the the the political star
[ __ ] I guess I don't really have a
problem with it III think it doesn't it
doesn't upset me maybe the way that it
upsets you because I do feel like like
in any profession most people in any
given profession are trying to do a good
job mm-hmm so like when I see Anderson
Cooper reporting on something I feel
like most the time he's doing a pretty
good job you know I think he's pretty
good uh Chuck Todd who I think can be a
little supercilious but I think he's
trying to do a good job and I think he's
doing I think he I think he approaches
things the way he approaches them for a
very specific reason it's thought it's
thought it's thought-out
yeah Jake Tapper the same way and you
know these guys will land punches that
kind of meshing of politico's and and
journalists doesn't really upset me
because it seems like well if you're a
journalist you want to have
relationships with these people to get
information yeah I guess for me the
bigger problem is that if you ask easy
questions and look I'm an interviewer so
if you ask easy questions you're gonna
get them to come back you know what I
mean so if I had Obama here one time and
I knew this is the one time that maybe
we'll set up the rest of our
relationship I don't
think I would attack him in a way that I
might the second time but even then that
butt kid that cars is a problem because
then they always go at a press
conference or he's like oh guy who I
know I get easy questions from you know
right but there's a way to have that
conversation have a tough conversation
with him or with anybody in a way that
he doesn't feel attacked you can I think
most politicians are receptive to being
asked to have questions in a respectful
way I thought Jon Stewart was was a
master at that yeah Jon Stewart would
have any conservative on his show he
would read their book and he would grill
them about it
it was always respectful and I think as
a consequence they would come on the
show because they knew they would get a
fair hearing for their ideas then they
may end up they may and they may walk
out feeling foolish but it's not because
of him it's because of them
you